foreign
left me and ran for safety in January of
22 because of my abusive Behavior what's
your abusive Behavior I was physical I
was emotional and verbal I was
financially abusive as well so you were
the worst yeah
[Music]
hey what up what up this is John with
the Dr John deloney's show the greatest
mental health and marriage podcast ever
so glad that you're with us and hey
Happy New Year we made it
I've got all of my toes crossed
underneath the desk here because I
record these shows a few weeks out and
so I'm hoping
that 22 2023 is off to a roaring start
Kelly you said you needed uh 2023 to go
good to go well to go to go gooder than
last year good grief
um the end of 2022 has smacked me upside
the head so I'm looking forward to 2020.
wrapping have you back thank you
everybody I'm sorry about your mom thank
you and she's lucky to have you I was
lucky to have her yeah yeah who is more
lucky let's get weird I'm just kidding
we won't do that hey uh it's 2023 we're
so uh happy that you're here we have a
special New Year's episode today we'll
take a few calls and we're going to talk
about resolutions and
um what you can do to make sure that
2023 is as best as you can control
because we all know that we can't
control things we can't control and um
most of us either spend our time
throwing our hands up going oh whatever
or gripping the wheels so tight we just
steered off into the ditch and so we're
gonna talk about what I'm doing in my
house what me and my family are doing
and what you can do in your home so
looking forward to it let's go out to
James in h-tone what's up James how we
doing
hey I'm I'm doing good uh super excited
to be on the show I'm excited to have
you man what's up how are you uh well I
just wanted to say first I'm super
honored to be able to talk with such an
intelligent and compassionate guy as you
I'm I'm pumped
so everybody in the booth compassionate
they'll go with uh intelligent they're
having a hard time competing and
Computing that but we'll take I'll take
it I'll take it so what's up man so
um well I uh I'll try not to preface you
to death with my question but uh no
preface me to death what else we got
going on let's do it
so uh I have it written down so I don't
go off too far
um but it's it's a it's a long preface
with a little question so I'm just gonna
read what I got here
it's a lot it's it's a lot uh so uh
Michael it says my wife left me and ran
for safety in January of 22 because of
my abusive Behavior Uh I've done well
since she left let me pause you I'm
gonna interrupt you as you read this
okay uh what's your abusive Behavior
uh I was physical and I was emotional
and verbal and
um I was also unaware but I was
financially abusive as well so you were
the worst
like crazy yeah okay 100 I was a
five-year-old in every uh in every way
possible absolutely and
um for what it's worth I'm proud to be
for recognizing that fact many many men
are terrible spouses like you were and
they never come to that realization so
good for you
um
let me ask you this oh yeah I'm sure
there is
um
when you say you were physical
were you threatening did you actually
punch her did you push her around paint
me a picture of what physical meant
yeah
so uh
I apologize I get emotional no it's okay
um
so uh
it escalated over time
but um
I uh
it started with verbal abuse and um it
translated from there into uh
changing walls uh throwing things a lot
of
uh
escalation over time ways that I didn't
behave
that I hadn't recognized since uh late
childhood and
um so
yeah it escalated to uh
shoving her onto the couch one day and
then shoving her to the floor the next
and then uh I would like squeeze her I
would put pressure on her legs because I
didn't want to hit her and um
it would leave bruises
and then um one day probably not one I
had probably it was about four years
into our marriage
um
it reached a pinnacle and
I uh
I I slapped her in the face and I spit
in her face and I shoved her to the
ground
and just pressed my arm into her leg
really hard and uh thankfully that was
the night that she left and um ran for
safety
what what happened in that moment that
that
you responded in that way
what had built up to that moment
it was a a lot of build up uh colleagues
um
I uh was wanting her to come pick me up
from a walk and she couldn't find me and
so uh
I got mad uh because she couldn't find
me she eventually found me but I just
wanted to walk and um mind you I was in
a deep deep I had in the last six months
prior I'd spent probably our entire
savings on uh my marijuana addiction to
try and run away we moved uh back to my
childhood town and we were trying to
adopt nine children and
um it fell through and we were our
marriage in the process fell through and
I was around all of my childhood
triggers and um every day I was just
running away more and more and that day
I was trying to
ah just get outside of myself and in any
way possible and um got home after the
uh Angry walk home when she couldn't
find me and um yeah it just blew up
and didn't know how to control myself in
that moment and uh yeah
so I have to be honest with you
um
guide a guy husband to husband
me being the dad of a six-year-old
little girl
there are some things I want to say
that wouldn't help the situation but it
would make me feel better
and so I need you to know and on behalf
of everybody listening I'm not going to
say that stuff it's not going to be
helpful to this conversation because you
know right
I I know and many people have told me my
mentor told me and uh yeah I've had lots
of people tell me what you I imagine you
would want to tell me
um it's my wife calls it I can feel it
um and she's pointed it out on me
um
she recognized back in college she would
grab my arm and say we need we need to
leave wherever we were like we need to
go right now and I'd be like no I'm fine
and she would say she's she eventually
told me she wouldn't tell me my tell
early on but
um she would say my jaw clinches in a
certain way that you're about to get in
a fight you're about to do something
stupid we need to go right now and I can
feel it on me now and so I'm not gonna
start a fight with you I'm not gonna try
to be tough in it because we're just on
a phone call here
um
what I what I want to start this call
with is this or not start this call but
I want to make sure I put this out there
you can be around childhood triggers you
can have some really cool expectations
for your life or some insane ones like
adopting nine kids thank God that fell
through thank God that filter
um
no those nine kids have no business
going to an addict abusive home right
um yeah I don't care how many triggers
you are I don't care which family
members you're around I don't care what
what childhood friends you end up I
don't care any of that crap
you have a choice to make in every
moment of your life right
awesome okay so you were abusive thank
God your wife left she took off on you
as she should have are y'all divorced
I'm proud of her uh it became official
uh
about two weeks ago okay so it took
about a year to go through the whole
process
yeah okay about 11 months okay
all right um so yeah I've uh I've had a
bit of a road to Damascus experience if
you will okay and um I uh I'll I'll try
to stay away from jargony talk but um
you listen to this show yeah be direct
I uh uh so yeah I mean
what it says here well I'm not gonna
read the script it's uh what what
changes have you made in your life
so many it's overwhelming rip them off
let's go
right so uh I've I'm down since uh
since late February I'm down 130 pounds
wow
I and it's not packing back on it's
intentional
um I go on a daily uh three to five mile
walk minimum no not minimum I I I go on
a daily three to five mile walk you
usually takes an hour to an hour and a
half uh I've read a lot of books
um I have gotten sorted out in my moral
values and I've got a mentor who has
poured his entire life into mine
I was able to I I quit my
antidepressants cold turkey uh not
advice I know but uh I was getting ready
to go to a drug rehab facility for a
year uh and I decided I didn't want to
do that I wanted to try and find a
different way and it's turned out really
well I've impressed some people but I
don't care about impressing people I
just want to be better
um I have
been able to maintain employment for a
long time
longer than normal I have been like 10
months
yeah that's not a long time
but it's longer than you have in the
past right
it's uh largely longer than most any
other job I've had all right we'll go
with that as a win keep going
I
started uh going back to school to
finish my bachelor's degree
um I started my business back up
um that was another thing that led to a
ton of depression uh because I didn't
have my business running and I was just
really futile living an aimless life
um
and yeah I so I I've gotten my my
physical health in order I've done well
to get my uh intellectual side going my
my spiritual health is really locked in
the most over anything and I'm just
trying to learn how to
overcome my traumas I feel like the
world owes me something and oh well I
often want to believe that the world
owes me something and that I'm entitled
to
some help and I'm not uh I'm not I'm 29
it's not cute anymore uh good for you
there's no sympathy and I need to grow
up and
um My ultimate question here is
I uh and I'm afraid to ask this too
because it's unbiased and I know you
tell the truth
um
I I miss my wife like crazy and um your
ex-wife I uh huh your ex-wife
uh yeah that uh
so I miss my ex-wife like crazy and um
um
I desire to uh have her uh gain her back
in my life and um my uh
uh that's a big long-term
dream of mine to have her back
um but the big thing here is um
so uh what would it take for me to have
a realistic shot at restoration and
Reconciliation of my marriage and
getting my wife back in my life if
that's ever possible again I'm I'm
committed to her and I'm committed to
whatever it takes to show her I'm
different and a new man I just my
responsibility uh waned and I have not
put in tons of work to overcome my
trauma
um
I'm not going to beat you up for wanting
to get your the woman that you love back
that makes sense to me
that you love her
and cosmically I honestly honestly in my
guts listening to your story don't
believe it's about her I don't think you
liked that guy who you became because
you became a monster
and not the monster you could control
you were an adult you were a child
monster which is the most dangerous kind
and I think you want to
um uh I think you want to redo that
and I do I think she's the person you
hurt so bad she is the shining example
of who you became when you were at your
worst
and
um you should 100 be in jail and you're
not
I agree right so when you became your
worst she is the poster of that
and so you want to go fix that and make
that right
okay
um so I don't fault you for that not
even a little bit
um
thankfully that's not your choice
yeah
I you've impressed me greatly with the
the work you've done very very
impressive this is a guy that fell over
the like it's like one of those uh Wiley
Coyote cartoons you've actually fell off
the cliff and there happened to be like
a one squirrely tree growing out of the
side of the cliff that you you know your
shirt caught on before you fell all the
way to your death and you managed to
claw and scratch your way back to the
top right
yeah I uh I also added I forgot to
mention that I did
um domestic abuse recovery program I've
been in therapy for the last uh eight or
nine months cool and I've done some
other emotional recovery no I got you I
got you
um so I'm the work you've put in is very
very impressive
very very impressive
all of these things on their own lose it
130 pounds it's it's damn near
impossible
um so choosing to have an hour
committing to an hour exercise program a
day if everyone in the United States did
that
um our country would be healed within 24
months I believe that with all my guts
if people just start walking and
exercising and waving to each other
um
reading is hard getting a mentor is hard
emotional recovery work is hard you've
done that you have not done the thing
that will take you a long time to do and
in fact you've circled it and avoided it
in a really masterful way
abusive people
and you you touched on it
are entitled
right that's that's that's the
foundation the world owes me you owe me
which is another way of saying you are
mine possessive right that you can do
all of the physical healing you want you
can do all the emotional and quote
unquote psychological healing you want
you can go get a anger management
certificate you can do all that stuff
it's all good it's all fine
but you have done zero
work relationally
I agree you don't know how to be in a
relationship
in relationships are the things that set
you off
somewhere along the way childhood trauma
is my guess is relationships were so
weaponized
there was such a point of fear and
anxiety and Terror for your little body
that it is unable to at this moment and
it can learn there is healing here
um but it's unable to be in them
because my guess is if you're if you're
a a mentor pushed you really hard you'd
eventually break that off
foreign
he's uh not giving up on me uh I know I
know but you're giving up on him yeah
there you go you've tried right
I uh I I met him through my church and
um in my church there are um uh it's my
biggest struggle uh I I am tempted to
say that I feel lonely often uh my my
relationships uh suffer I don't I don't
have a ton of uh I I have my gang of
guys that I can go to and tell them
anything but uh I don't have yeah
relationships it's my big struggle for
sure
and that your gang of guys that you can
tell quote unquote anything to
let me be real clear
my gang that's like that
Trevor and Michael and Craig and Kevin
and Todd
and
John
if I called them and told them that I
was up for a walk and I asked them to
come my wife to come pick me up and she
couldn't find me to the point that I
choked her and shoved her to the ground
and injured her
brother God help me
foreign
yeah so I'm calling BS on these guys you
can tell everything to
I didn't have them prior okay so you are
practicing being in relationship here's
all I'm telling you number one doing all
of this work with a goal to get back
with an ex-wife who you are highly
abusive to
is not the point
because all of his hinges on something
that's out of your control
which is her choosing somewhat
psychopathologically
to get back into a relationship with a
guy that's physically and emotionally
and psychologically assaulted her over a
long period of time
okay you have to do this because you're
worth being well and stopping this
madness from taking another inch of your
family tree
and you still don't believe you're worth
all of this
you don't
some days I do but uh not not uh largely
no yes the internal narrative is you
know I'm a piece of crap and yeah I need
to give up because uh it's been long
enough and no nothing good has come from
it well good things have come from it
but not what you want so just go ahead
and do that incredible things have come
from this
but not that core which is the world
owes me
and you nailed it the world owes us
nothing we all leave this thing in a box
right
all of us do
and so until you switch the dial from
I'm doing all this stuff and dude you've
done hard hard things I'm doing this so
that I can get like I can get my trophy
back dude I'm telling you right now this
ends in Ash
if you do this because James from
Houston is worth going to bed at night
without any meds
James is worth sitting around with a
bunch of guys laughing James is worth
getting upset and having a set of uh
Tools in his toolkit to not rage out on
his poor wife who just was trying to
find him and he gave bad directions
or she sucks at read the map who cares
right
until you believe that all of this is
you just extra I mean this is just a
long exercise in white knuckling
okay
I was like
it feels like uh a never-ending striving
you know why because you're still trying
to achieve love and you've been doing
this since you were six stop
foreign
you cannot achieve love my friend
you have to receive it
and receiving means opening your hands
and opening your hands means
vulnerability and vulnerability means
somebody may hurt you real real bad and
instead of allowing that to happen you
hurt them first
and until you flip that over my friend
you're going to be in a steady
loop-de-loop de loop-de-loop d loop de
loop of look what I did now look what I
did now look what I did now look what I
did now
and that core
rage underneath is going to keep burning
and burning and burning and running and
running and running and running
um I I'm I'm stunned that I'm saying
this
I'm really proud of you you've worked
really hard
and for you to say it's all amounted to
nothing is it dishonest that's a lie
it's amounted to a lot
you lost 130 pounds you've changed your
entire physical physiological being
you've started practicing relationships
subjecting yourself to hard stuff
what I'm suggesting is
time to put all of this work into the
relationship side
because you're not telling that group of
guys everything you're not
you haven't told them
um you don't tell them all the good
stuff you don't tell them all the bad
stuff and more importantly you don't
tell them what happened to you when
you're a kid
grief demands a witness the things that
happen to you you're gonna have to look
somebody and say them out loud
somebody that could use them against you
and then they don't
and your body relaxes and breathes
because it's safe for the first time in
a long long long time
and that sense of safety that sense of
that allows other people to enter into
your space further and deeper and that's
intimacy that's relationship that's love
so you man you're on the right path
you've made a turn that very very few
men make and I'm proud of you
foreign
but getting your wife back can't be the
goal here because you can't control what
she decides to do with her life
all you can control is you
and hear me say this and if you're
watching this I'm looking directly at
the camera you're worth this
[Music]
do this for you
do this for your many use
am I in I the little James's that come
down the road
they're going to be born one day
so that them and their spouses never
experience this
learn relationship and learn love
[Music]
and maybe your wife will call you back
but your ex-wife will call you back one
day probably not
Maybe
but that's not the goal Loving You Is
we'll be right back
hey everybody happy New Year deloni here
and I bet you're waiting for me to get
all sarcastic and make fun of New Year's
resolutions and okay it is funny to me
that we give each other a mulligan for
whatever we did last year because hey
it's a new year we get to start over but
I actually like New Year's and I love
New Year's resolutions intentional
resolutions can help you define what's
going to be true for you this year and a
great resolution we can all make is to
prioritize being well and that means
creating healthy practices moving your
body and here's the quickest Improvement
you can make prioritizing sleep sleep is
crucial for your mental and physical
health and good sleep starts with a
great mattress and that's why I
recommend dream cloud and right now
dream cloud is running an offer just for
my listeners get 25 off any mattress
plus 599 dollars in accessories and an
additional 50 discount when you use the
promo code John deloney it's one word so
go to dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code John deloney to get your new
mattress today
all right we are back let's go out to
Melissa in Mansfield Ohio what's up
Melissa
hi Dr John thanks for taking the call of
course thanks for calling what's
happening how can I help
I'm wondering at what point do I
distance myself and my children away
from my parents or keep fighting for the
relationship
that sounds heavy tell me more
so about 10 years ago my husband and I
made the decision that we wanted to
leave the Mennonite community and
culture
and my parents didn't take it very well
and they said that
I needed to still wear a covering
to be welcome in their home
so we decided okay we can do that and we
did that for many years we tried our
best to honor that request
and then
um
lately I'm just feeling like I I'm done
I want to be accepted for who I am
and my sisters and I were in a prayer
study time for a while and I found out
recently that my mom wants to
not be part of it because I don't wear
uh head covering to pray
and I'm just not sure if I
have the strength to keep fighting or if
it's just time to
walk away
so I'm going to say something really
hard
that you know innately in in your bones
but I'm gonna say it out loud okay okay
your parents have chosen their faith
over you
yeah
and so it's not a matter of you
continuing to fight for a relationship
it's a matter of you accepting a reality
and where it lies
and I'm not going to judge your parents
and I'm not going to judge you
all have each made the decisions that
have brought you here
if you feel that you can no longer wear
a head covering I applaud you from the
depths of my soul because I know what
that value costs you and our values
always cost us things
whether it's jobs or relationships or
whatever they always have a have a price
to pay
um
and in a sideways way I've I applaud
your parents they're willing to lose
their daughter
uh-huh that's that's one heck of a value
proposition that they have are
subscribing to
right yeah what gets stuck in the
crosshairs is
you're just a girl who wants her mom
and Mom is saying I'll only take you if
you if you dress right
and at the core of our guts that hurts
man I'm so sorry
yeah it does and you just want your kids
to go play with their granddad like you
have in their that picture in your head
around the fireplace
and Granddad says I'd love to but you
gotta dress right
otherwise you're not welcome in my house
right and that hurts bad doesn't it
yeah
and
exhale because I can feel it on you
exhale out
it is it just is
so there is no fight here
okay there's grief
yeah
and grief is not something you do with
your fist grease grief is something you
do
with your hands wide open it is yeah
and
um
I'm really sorry
because you've had this idea that if I
just keep playing the charade or I just
keep pretending that everything's gonna
be okay and it hasn't been okay for a
decade
right
they've they've changed
no I know it will but they're allowed to
yeah and you're allowed to change yours
okay they're grown-ups and so I'm not
gonna fight what was I'm not gonna fight
what I want to be
I'm going to accept it I'm going to have
my heart broken by it I'm going to be
grieved by it and then I'm going to
figure out what comes next
because because what's the alternative
there is no other alternative other than
to
continue with the charade something that
I'm not something I don't believe in and
teach my kids that your values are only
as strong as your cowardice
or and that your kids will feel that
tension leading up to the three weeks to
go visit Grandma and Granddad they're
gonna feel that awkwardness while you're
there
and only is going to get worse as you
get old don't subject them to that
they're already bringing up questions
they're already starting
of course
yeah
of course and they're like they're I
would hope you're raising kids and ask
good card questions right
yeah so they made their choice and now
you've got to make yours
and so if your mom chooses to not be a
part of your new Bible study because of
how you dress she's allowed to make that
choice
and you can tell her hey we'll continue
to set a spot for you because we'll miss
you
and that might be some time of weeping
that might you be you writing a letter
to her that you're never going to send
that you put in the fireplace sometime
in January but you write the letter and
just say hey
you're my mom and you're supposed to
love me whether I've got certain clothes
on or not
and I miss you
and here's what you're gonna miss you're
going to miss your daughter and you're
going to miss your grandkids
but I've got to find people that are 5
10 15 years ahead of us me and me and my
husband that we got that can mentor us
that can be there for our kids because
y'all are choosing to not
and that's that's their choice
right yeah
I really really hate this for you I hate
this for them
I can't imagine they want to be losing
their daughter and grandkid grandkids
yeah so what comes next
let them know that we probably won't be
at their holiday get-togethers
or maybe this year
you guys just let them know hey we're
gonna do we're doing another thing this
year
leave them out of the equation
this year we're not going to travel this
year we're gonna we're doing our own um
this smaller family intimate Gathering
we wish y'all Merry Christmas
kids can FaceTime Grandma and Granddad
and call it
make this about you you're making
grown-up choices
the fight's over putting my son putting
my swords and my shield down
to explain it to our children
uh how old are your kids
than the nine
um
that's probably a little bit too young
for them to fully grasp the gravity of
things and so I would let them know that
this year y'all just made some choices
that we're gonna We're not gonna go to
Grandma and Grandad's this year
we're gonna do Christmas at home
but why why
it's just gonna be best for our family
this year
okay what are two or three things you
guys want to do
and be very certain that on Christmas
morning or whenever y'all do your time
together with your family
um
sad
feel it
and let your kids know I'm just missing
Grandma and Granddad
tell them I miss him this year oh why
don't we go see him hey it wasn't good
it wasn't good for us this year
foreign
at some point you will have to say
I no longer buy into this particular
parts of this religion
and I don't believe in wearing a head
covering and Grandma and Granddad said
that either I wear a head covering or
I'm not welcome in their home
and either y'all wear head coverings
you're not welcome in their home
and I chose to follow my beliefs and my
values
and at some point you have that
conversation with them probably closer
to 11 or 12.
okay and they can fully grasp it and I
think you do it not out of spite or
hatred and your grandparents sting go to
no right I mean they think this is a a
an
eternal decision they're they're they're
making they wouldn't stake their
relationship with their daughter and
their grandkids if they didn't think
that right so cool I'm not gonna fault
you for it
but I don't have to participate because
I'm an adult
see what I'm saying this this is the
language of somebody who has stopped the
war
okay
okay and this is gonna by the way you've
been fighting for a decade you're gonna
have to learn a new identity you haven't
lived in peace time
correct you don't know how to live in
peace time and my guess is your mom has
been
oh geez
y'all have been fighting for a lot
longer than just 10 years is that fair
uh yeah
you don't know how to live in peace time
so I want you and your husband
um to go spend some time
mapping out what a peaceful life is
going to look like let's build this
thing and let's try to lean into it
let's just don't wander off into the
desert because you're going to run out
of water
uh-huh
is that cool yeah
hang on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of uh own your past change your
future for you and your I'm gonna send
you two of them both for you and your
husband to read together and y'all can
highlight your own keep by each other by
the bed
and then you can walk through all right
in this upcoming new year what do we do
what do we do next
um after we have to own here's what has
happened here are the stories we were
born into and here's the stories we're
not carrying with us anymore
um and by the way if you're listening to
this on January 2nd or after the new
year I realize that sounds pretty
strange because we record this before
actually before the Christmas holiday
and so
um
you may have already endured Christmas
holidays or are experiencing the back
half of your first year of boundaries
just know
um
as you head into 2023
the more you can own reality
the more you can give other adults in
your life the grace and opportunity to
make the choices they want to make
like the first caller you want to hit me
cool I'm out
actually that's that's a terrible
example because in no way is that cool
um you're going to jail and I'm leaving
um you want me to do something that goes
against my core religious values great
you're not welcome here or great I'm not
coming
you want me to do what it work yeah I'm
not doing that
um I wish you the best you as a business
owner are allowed to demand that of your
employees I'm going to choose to not be
one of them and I may not be able to
choose it right now but I'm going to
spend the next 18 months working three
jobs or four jobs
and getting myself in a position so I
never
ever have to take this again
[Music]
I'm not gonna fight you
I'm just gonna head out
and I've created a non-anxious life that
allows me to do that
[Music]
2023 is going to be the year where we
lay the swords down and the shields down
stop fighting
and we just go live our lives
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement and MLS ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
what's up we are back in it and it is
time for every favorite I literally
think this is nobody's favorite for the
lightning round it's Kelly's favorites
the late night dive bar music
yeah I'd like a bush draft on draft what
is it
I'd like Bush lightning on draft is that
a thing I I don't know
no Kelly's like no those are back in the
old days I'm not real sure that
that sounds like you're like Miller Lite
on tap well there is
a Coors Light In A Bottle or something
like that that's PBR to me oh there we
go PBR no because PBR is ironic PBR is
like Weezer now there's like a hipster
thing yeah it's like really tight jeans
and mustaches for people Natty light
Natty light and if you on tap that's
that music yes and a marble red just
because you have to
you can't you can't drink Natty light
and just have it be in your body do you
have a package exactly so it's a
two-for-one all right so here we are
lightning round
so we got through the old disgusting
beers yes welcome 2023. all right let's
do it so this uh lightning round is
about goals and resolutions how fitting
and cute I may have been planned maybe
maybe yeah it's my favorite time I love
it I know everybody gets a start to do
over oh no all right question one are
you ready Ben with the timer
what's the difference between goals and
resolutions
um I I tend to
um believe resolutions are about an
identity change I am I'm resolving too
take care of better care of my body I am
resolving to
um be a better husband I'm resolving
those kind of I resolved this year to be
on time uh a goal is
I will
um leave my house by 7 15 every day I
will lose 25 pounds by February 1st
forever so goals are these tangible
markers on the way to a resolution
that's what I look at him
I like that I ever thought of it that
way you're so smart oh no that one guy
called me intelligent earlier let's go
with smart let's start
all right second one I want to read more
next year how can I get into a good
habit
um
uh three things number one change your
identity I'm a person who reads that's
who I am and then create some behaviors
are going to back that up so leave your
phone in your car take a book in with
you when you go to Walmart
um and you're waiting for your oil to
get changed
um always always I've got I always have
a book on me at all times 24 7 365 and
even I have one when I'm hunting in the
woods I got a book in my bag like I
always have a book with me
um because one of my identities is I'm a
guy that reads the third thing is is
make it easy
um have a book by your bed have a book
by have your reading environment already
set up so it's not so hard and then I
think the fourth thing would be
um even if you can only read half of a
page a day
you're eventually going to get through a
book and so just because you don't have
two hours to read or I was going to read
an hour this morning then I got up late
cool read for five minutes just read
every single day and over time if you're
a reader
um you'll get through more books and
you'll begin reading more and more and
more you'll create that space
practice that's a better word awesome
best advice for new Dads going into the
new year
man the best advice I could give new
dads the advice that saved me was not a
hack or not a hey you should it was
getting a couple of dads who were five
ten years ahead of me 15 years ahead of
me that I could call and reach out to
and ask questions about the second thing
is is your experience as a dad is very
different than your
Partners experience so listen
stop ex explaining your experience as
the only experience going on in your
home somebody else is having a totally
radically different experience so commit
to listening so get some mentors get
some people not just some friends who
are further along down the road they'll
roll their eyes and laugh at you or
they'll be like that's not a big deal or
no you need to stop that right now you
need to get on that one right now and um
start listening more ta-da yeah
all right every year I set a goal to
work out more but I never stick to it
how do I actually follow through
uh
um
my workout honestly I can just say about
me personally
um it shifted when
I had a total it was a
it was a more Global conversation with
myself again you hear me say it's all
time change your identity I I just
decided I was gonna be a guy that took
better care of his body I wanted to be a
a Granddad or a great Granddad that
could roll around with my grandkids on
on our wrestling match when I was 90.
and so what I have to do right now I got
to stop eating the way I eat I got to
start sleeping I gotta start doing some
of these other things and so exercise
became one piece of a much larger puzzle
it wasn't that I was just like eating
McDonald's every day and I was staying
up all night and I was laid everywhere
and then I tried to add working out that
never works it had to be a part of a
bigger shift
um the second thing is is it didn't
really change for me until I got
um some things at my house that I could
do and for me it started with a jump
rope and a couple of kettlebells maybe
some dumbbells
um and then I moved on to like the squat
rack I got off Craigslist and then I
moved on to another thing and then
another thing and now I've got a whole
set at my house but I made it really
easy
so if I could just do five minutes I'm
just gonna go do five minutes and that
morphed into what it is today
I want to change my eating habits this
year breaking the cycle of eating more
that I need or lots of sweets where do I
start
um I have had my whole life
revolutionized with the carbon app and
so I'd reach out to those guys Dr Lee
Norton and that crew get on the App
Store I make no money off this deal it's
just been something that's been really
helpful for me and it is hard
on Friday night or Saturday at a party
to try to figure out I hate it like I
hate not only hate the app I hate
learning how to be intentional about
what I eat but um until you I mean you
change what you measure right and until
you track and measure what you're
actually eating all the time it's really
hard to be like I'm just gonna think
about eating differently you gotta
actually follow it and carbon app is the
best of the best of the best
it's worth the money
when it comes to goals I start off
strong and then lose Steam how do I stay
motivated and accountable
as you're asking that I was gonna say
um have some people that keep you
accountable in your life and your this
is from James clear you're only as good
as your systems you're not you can't
always rely on your goals you're only as
good as the systems you've set up for
yourself and so if every day you get off
of work and you don't have dinner plans
already or every day you leave for work
and you have it meal prepped well you're
at the mercy of your calendar of
whatever they're cooking down in the
cafeteria what friend comes by and says
hey let's go get lunch somewhere you're
at the mercy of everybody else and so
you're only as good as your systems and
so if you want to change the way you eat
you just got to start with with I mean
if you want to change your goals you
just got to be highly intentional about
the systems you set up to make those
goals very easy going back to talking
about reading carry a book with you
everywhere it makes wanting to read more
so much easier if you always have a book
on you
foreign
what happens when you reach the goals
you've set and then you feel lost
um that's usually somebody that's
um yeah has not gone with the identity
shift they've just made a bunch of goals
and they thought when I cross a Finish
Line then my dad's going to call me out
of the blue and say you know what I'm
proud of you when I finally make six
figures I make a hundred thousand
dollars in a year
then my old high school girlfriend's
gonna call and be like I never should
have left and you'll be like I know and
I'm gonna hang up
um
as soon as I finally lose 40 pounds then
finally that old boyfriend is gonna call
and be like
I saw your photos on Facebook you're so
that's never gonna happen that actually
might because men are disgusting but
like there's this idea that when I
accomplish a set of goals I'm gonna feel
a certain way
and it simply doesn't play out like that
the data says that
so many attorneys who make partner
actually have a fall off they feel like
I give up my 20s and 30s for this like
this is what I gave up for and so shift
your identity first this is who I am and
here's why
and that has a much longer
um then you're on you're on an adventure
you're not just trying to hit hit a
marker
that makes sense I feel like I was
rambling a little bit on that one but I
hope that makes sense I think it does
okay yeah
although we did think that the when your
ex-girlfriend calls you and says she
never should have broke up was very
oddly specific I'm just Hey listen
listen that's for another episode I
haven't run that by my wife I can tell
those stories yet one day all right next
question how do I help my teenagers
learn to set goals
oh there's just one way
teenagers watch you
and so if you are a disciplined person
who creates identity I would suggest
everybody this start this New Year with
an identity board here's who we are as a
family that goes on the board I mean
somewhere in your house it's prominent
uh here's who we are and then they watch
you live them
and then you provide opportunity for
them to live into them as well
but until they see you do it I mean
you're just you're just
I almost said pissing in the wind but I
thought better about it so I didn't say
it ta-da
apparently we need to work on how
microphones work
anywho all right
how do I encourage my spouse to stay on
top of their goals
if I was your spouse I wouldn't want to
work on my goals if that was your
attitude
um honestly you can't you can't you can
only control you
um you can be very disciplined and taken
care of yourself and making sure that
you are are creating space where people
feel
um where their needs are met I guess the
one thing you could do and I'm thinking
this out loud you can
ask what do you need from me to make it
possible for you to be able to do the
things that you need to do to stay well
and so
um I've got a series of things in my
house that I that I keep like if I see
dishes in the sink then I try to just
stop what I'm doing and just knock them
out because I know that gives my wife
not only five minutes of doing the
dishes but it gives her 10 minutes of
thinking about it and then she has to
schedule it between grabbing the kids
and doing it and so it just it ends up
the domino effect ends up opening a lot
of her day so what can I do to help meet
your your needs so that you can help
take care of yourself but other than
that I can't make anybody nagging
complaining those things never ever ever
work in fact they cause the opposite
all right last one what are the goals
you and your team have set for 2023
what are y'all's goals
check me everybody look down like
it was like the math teacher like all
right we're going to talk about
equations and everyone just like looks
at the floor hoping they don't get
called on
am I going first I'll go first okay
um I I never really do goals I just I
maybe because you are the associate
producer of this show now you have to I
know I know I have to Let's that still
goes out okay well I have I have one in
my mind of what I want to do because
it's just the following through part
that I always Trail off you know I'm in
that group of like oh I set big goals
January come February 1st they're gone
okay so we'll see but I have never
really had like a nightly or a morning
routine and I find that I just feel
tired and dragged through the day
because like I get up in the morning and
I just hit snooze like 10 times and then
I get up and I rush through getting
ready I don't eat breakfast and I go out
the door so I'd like to develop some
sort of structure
where I have like okay by this time I'll
do this and then I eat breakfast because
you know apparently that's important
um and see if it helps my like
um my energy levels throughout the day
that's a pretty long goal so what if we
instead of focusing on that goal first
what what is an identity that goes
beyond that
I don't know
like I want to be the best
version of myself I can be I'm a person
who
shows up at work ready to go yes I think
so I because I I find myself in the boat
of like I get here at like 805. you know
like I just want to be able to be
somebody who gets to work
at a prompt time and I have like a set
schedule but you see how all those
things work together so yes maybe it's I
am a person who wants to show up at work
ready to rock and roll
um and so backing that up we all know
that like hitting snooze has a whole
biochemical Cascade that just it ruins
your day it really does it does and so
does not it may be for some of people
not eating breakfast and not exercising
and not whatever the series of steps are
right
um but I'm just the kind of woman who
shows up ready to rock and roll that's a
different that's a new Jenna
do it we're going to be clipping that
I'm just the kind of woman that shows up
ready to rock and roll by the way
John deloney that's on the Internet it's
now on the internet we already put it up
there
awesome awesome
uh all right I I uh anybody else
uh I wasn't prepared to answer this
question but one thing is that I my goal
is to finish my novel okay this year and
so the identity piece that you're
talking about is that I am a writer a
person that writes and so in order to do
that I have to write ah because writers
write every day yes and so like George R
Martin
he's written great stuff I don't
consider him a writer because he doesn't
sit down right you know I'm saying we're
still waiting on that 10th book or
whatever yes Stephen King writes two
thousand words a day every day and so
he's a writer he's got a new book every
day that's right I'm ready to go so and
so in 2023 Ben is a writer yes fantastic
yes and manifesting it
the lead singer of dump button all right
um ours has been or mine my husband and
I have been working on
changing our identity around
Health health-wise
um and we've uh he's had some health
issues that have affected our lives in
our marriage and we have decided we
really want to change that so we want to
be a couple that
um
that is healthy and that travels and
that we will have an empty nest here in
about two years somewhere in the next
couple years and we want to be able to
go and do things
um and not be held back by that so we're
we did which uh what you talked about
earlier we have outfitted our bonus room
upstairs for everything we need
um with weights and the rowing machine
and all of that stuff and we're slowly
starting to do some things the last
couple weeks have kind of knocked us off
kilter a bit so just being intentional
about
um about our habits and supporting each
other more than that which we haven't
always done
so I love love the idea of saying okay
we got two years to empty nesters
to
celebrate and grieve being empty nesters
we're going somewhere and we want to be
able to do the following things there
and so how much money do do we need to
have 24 months out how much
um if we're going to be hiking we gotta
be in this kind of shape right we want
to have this kind of boom chicka wow so
I want it right whatever and so like I
love the idea of just simply putting on
a calendar in reverse engineering it
doesn't sound as sexy as let's just go
to Italy and like yeah that's just not
how the world Works only in Hollywood
that would be incredible I mean you set
yourself up for 24 months they're going
to be tough and hard and a trip that's
going to be incredible
they're good for you
thanks
all right
um
Andrew's just staring down all right
here's here's uh I'll just I'll I'll
save you
um all right here's mine
um
one two three four five I got six
categories here
um two supersede the category supersede
all the categories one is
um
pathologically
insanely on time always
forever I'm making that my number one
priority
um and so I have to reverse engineer
every other part of my life to go
through that funnel weirdly that means
that I have to turn my phone off the
night before and I can't turn it back on
until I'm at work because I just find
myself done a Vortex
um
et cetera et cetera et cetera I will
have to be pathologically on time that
means I'm gonna have to be very early to
things for a long time until I practice
and learn the second thing is the
Simplicity anti-clutter anti-chaos as
I've been working and writing this new
book on creating a non-anxious life I
keep coming to the literature that talks
about how clutter and all the crap we
have at our houses just are burying us
um how much we always have headphones in
our ears uh all those things so
anti-clutter and anti-chaos simplicity
Simplicity Simplicity Simplicity
um next is more adventures and that's
everything from concerts to late night
trips to hunting trips to travel I'm
just gonna go be more adventurous
um I find myself getting kind of boring
and so we're just gonna go take a
midnight run and we're gonna go do
something fun
um loneliness I found myself really
lonely after all the travel and writing
this year so friends connection doing
things with new folks making new friends
my wife and I have some internal like we
want to continue to be the best married
couple we can be and so we're gonna have
some very direct goals about sex and
intimacy and that means we talk about it
openly which is kind of part of the fun
um we have some financial goals some big
things we want to buy and save for et
cetera and then for work um and I'd
guess the goals for our team
man to blow the lid off this show off
both the podcast and the YouTube show
and to make some really remarkable leaps
in how many people were able to just
serve and help across the globe and the
show's just grown like crazy this year
and that's a hundred percent thanks to
you all listening
um and the goal now is to start 2x 3x 5x
10xing at all and we've got some cool
things coming down the way that I think
are going to get us there so thank you
so so much for sticking with us this is
the New Year's episode who are you gonna
be this year
who are you going to be and what are the
things you're going to do on a daily
basis a weekly monthly basis they're
going to get you tour they're gonna
direct you towards the person you want
to become we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap it up you know
we're going here dude it's YouTube's New
Year's Day
it's the song is going to launch us into
2023.
song goes like this all is quiet on New
Year's Day a world in white gets
underway I want to be with you be with
you night and day nothing changes on New
Year's Day I will be with you again
under a Blood Red Sky a crowd is
gathered in black and white arms
entwined The Chosen Few the newspaper
says say it's true it's true and we can
break through the torn and two we can be
one I will begin again maybe the time is
right maybe tonight or maybe right now
make today the day you say no more let's
just make a difference and go make it
happen just do it see you soon